[MUSIC PLAYING]
This might look familiar.
You've got a different
tool for every task.
Firebase can help you
simplify, making it easier
to create an app with
features that work together,
all in one place, packaged
into a single SDK.
With Firebase, you'll
get real support
so you can build
faster and focus on
the things that matter most.
Develop your app
across platforms
on iOS, Android, and the web.
But we know success starts
with your first users,
so we've got tools for this too.
Firebase Crash Reporting helps
you make your app stronger,
with the details you need
to fix the trickiest glitch.
And at its core,
Firebase Analytics
gives you more insight so you
can act on the latest trends
and stay close to
your users, growing
with them into the millions.
It's app success made simple
for whatever you're building.
Develop, grow, and
earn with Firebase.